i am wonder mike and i've come to say
hello to the black to the white the red
and the brown the purple and yellow but
first i've got to gotta introduce our
guest because
though i think we ought to you know all
just sort of get along and be nice to
people regardless of their sex or their
race
the left doesn't want to let us do that
and this is especially true
in entertainment i just saw a post from
the american booksellers association the
american book sellers association is
hosting and a free anti-racism workshop
titled what's up with white women
unpacking sexism and white privilege in
pursuit of racial justice well to help
me break down this story i
i have invited on one of these much
maligned white women this would be megan
basham a rotten tomatoes approved critic
entertainment reporter for the daily
wire
uh you have uh seen her and heard her
before and you may have seen her book
beside every successful man out from
random house megan thank you for coming
on
thanks so much for having me so megan
defend yourself i am told that white
women karen's in particular some of the
worst creatures
ever to curse the face of the earth so
what do you have to say for yourself
you know and isn't that funny i if if
people saw the image
for this workshop it had an image of a
crying woman
white women's tears we hear a lot about
that these days and it was funny because
for the first time it hit me that karen
is a racial slur right right right i
mean and i don't i don't know why it
didn't hit me before but i thought you
call us karen's based on our skin color
and our gender so it's also misogynistic
so um could you imagine megan if someone
if uh
some group of people just referred
derisively to a shaniqua said oh you're
such a shaniqua i mean could you ima you
would be you would be censored to be
ostracized from society or to a uh
i don't know what's a good uh what's a
good uh hispanic name like uh maria or
something oh she's such a maria
such a maria yeah yes could you imagine
of course not but uh you know but it's
it's sort of point i almost don't even
say could you imagine if we're on the
other foot because we're not living in a
time that cares at all about hypocrisy
it's about hierarchies that some people
are better than others that's kind of
the point of this intersectionality
anti-racism thing is that white people
are bad and every other kind of person
is good and that that's it but once you
get past all the pretentious jargon that
is what is at the heart of critical race
theory and its various derivations
well and i think when you really look at
um this organization there's a back
story here that's kind of fascinating
and it's also really disturbing um this
summer
they they work with independent book
groups they work with independent
bookstores and they send out
sample books
for them to consider stocking shelves
and publishers pay to put books in there
and this summer there was a huge hubbub
with this organization so first they
included abigail schreier's book regnery
paid to include abigail schreyer's book
it's critical of the transgender
movement among children
in that book box and people lost their
minds and they also
mistook candace owen's book blackout for
another title of the same name that were
written by several social justice young
adult authors it was a young adult teen
romance
and they ended up
apologizing for the
racist violence that they perpetrated uh
on behalf of booksellers to the people
who received these books so here they
are putting out an organ they're putting
out an event called
what's up with white men women while
they're meanwhile
slandering candace owens slandering
abigail schreier saying that they are
racist and violent
and uh and then they have ironically two
white women leading this seminar
and then to get even a little further
into the irony about this whole
organization which is very influential
within the publishing business they've
been around for over a hundred years
they have very deep roots um they host
something called banned books week it's
going on right now cnn is covering it so
after this whole thing happened this
summer they promised they would never
send their members books like that again
and now they're celebrating banned books
week i guess i should say celebrating
because now they're a part of banning
books right you know it's funny because
in a way this is this was kind of the
premise of my book that i recently came
out with which i suspect the american
booksellers association doesn't care for
very much which is
you know
we
have have long talked a good game on how
it's terrible to ban books or and we
should never do that and everything we
should have total free speech absolutism
but that has never existed anywhere in
to my mind and it's we know that the
left are hypocrites on this but but
conservatives i think should recognize
there's nothing particularly
conservative about saying that we ought
to you know encourage any sort of book
whether it's obscene or vicious or
anything like that i mean there's
there's book burning in the bible plato
advocates for book burning for goodness
sakes i mean every society has some
kinds of standards and and taboos and it
seems to me what the left has done and
they've got they've gone into the
american booksellers association and
they've just changed all the standards
and taboos and and now they're they're
holding these anti-racism seminars
obviously to promote racism the thing
that's really weird to me though is
i think white women read books don't
they aren't don't they buy books why are
they turning off this huge segment of
their customer base
not only do they buy books they are
actually
the largest demographic of book buyers
so this is really kind of a very poor
business move for
a group a industry independent
booksellers that are dying they're
struggling to stay up stay alive and
this is their reaction to that it's
really hard to wrap your mind around
what they're thinking but i think they
would say that the type of books that
they want to protect
in the public space is in schools there
we've seen a lot of stories lately about
pornographic material being in books for
children and they want to protect those
in school libraries and school
classrooms so those are the kind of
books that they're advocating for at the
aba right it candace owens a black woman
saying think for yourself that's got to
be banned that you've got to burn at the
pyre in the center of the community but
some filthy degenerate porn like you're
seeing in the fairfax county schools
that should be assigned to third graders
that's i'm being only slightly
hyperbolic that that is the argument
that we're hearing from these people
that is the argument
you know moving on from the uh white
women i i want to be fair i want to give
you equal time here to that other evil
rotten terrible group white men now i
say this my so i guess i'm a white man
i'm a little swarthy i don't know quite
quite where i fall on that scale but but
i was reading not just on some random
post from the american booksellers
association
i was reading about the evils of white
men
in an actually more sophisticated
publication
scientific american scientific american
just came out and uh they they attacked
the jedi the the
mythical series of you know group of
heroes in the star wars movies
apparently some social justice warriors
have adopted this phrase jedi for
themselves because they support justice
and equity and diversity and inclusion
get it wakawaka so they're calling
themselves jedi and scientific american
is saying no
jet that's that's bad jedi are are
upholders of the patriarchal
cisgender white normative or whatever
nonsense they spout and actually we've
got to we've got to cancel luke
skywalker
well you know it's really fascinating to
look at the story so i wrote up an
article on this and when i was looking
at it i went
we're running out of things to cancel
because who doesn't love star wars that
we're now we've now gotten to the bottom
of the barrel where we have to complain
about using star wars but i do think
that there's something a little bit
bigger behind this story and that's that
when you look at the american
imagination when you look at the kinds
of stories that we have as a culture
loved for decades
the left is going to have to start
changing those kind of stories because
star wars itself is a group of
liberty valuing individual freedom
fighters
going against the leviathan they're
going against the central power
that's not a story that an authoritarian
movement's gonna love
so it feels very specific that you're
starting to see them turn again we've
already turned against your john wayne
your westerns and in a way star wars is
the inheritor of that western
imagination um so i'm looking at this
story going not only that it's yes it's
it's eastern mysticism a little bit but
it's also a story of a religious
reawakening of people who are starting
to go maybe there's something bigger
than the state out there maybe some
bigger force has control over what
happens in our lives
none of these things are the kind of
things that your social justice warriors
of today are going to be really hip on
also since when is yoda a white guy i
thought he was a green girl i didn't
know he was a guy at all i thought he
was some kind of animal but but it does
i guess it does show you yes i i agree
with your points i i think that's a a
great observation that in order for the
left to transform the country they've
got to change all of the stories but
then there's even this battle amongst
themselves for what what does the story
mean you know on the one hand they they
see that the the jedi in star wars are
the good guys so they want to
take on
they want to associate themselves with
the good guys in the movies but because
they're not the good guys because in
real life they're the bad guys they've
also then got to attack
the good guys and they've got to make
the bad guys the good guys it's a very
complicated process
it really is and you know i always kind
of enjoy these stories when you really
dig down into what's happening
with culture what's happening with the
larger myths that we tell ourselves
because i find it really fascinating
that it used to be white guys who are
kind of dominated the science world and
they love stories of
space and anything that sort of feeds
into that scientific
genre that they live in and suddenly
they're saying you don't really get to
have this anymore you don't get to think
that the stories you grew up on are cool
anymore we're going to take that away
from you too and we're going to absorb
you into the collective hive mind and
that's what's happening to me yeah i i
think it is and so people are tuning
this out you see this in a lot of
different places but nobody watched the
emmy awards the other night even i i
mean it is it is my job to cover events
like the emmy awards i get a paycheck on
the assumption that i will watch events
like the emmy awards and i'm glad
shapiro's out today so he can't hear
this i didn't i didn't i can't bring
myself to that's no paycheck is worth it
and and certainly people who weren't
being paid did not watch it and by the
way at the emmy awards you were seeing a
difference between the ruling class and
the ruled at the emmy awards
even though there's an la mask mandate
people weren't wearing masks they were
in enclosed space but they weren't
wearing masks and they were prattling on
about how the rest of us need to wear
masks and i wonder if that if that plays
a little bit into it as well that the
the makers of culture are their own
insular elite group in a way that is
disconnected from the people and in a
way that is different than we've seen in
the past in america and
how long can they sustain that before
they lose whatever influence they they
now retain
i don't know i guess you know ask 18th
century france how long can you sustain
this how long does it go on before
people start to realize that we're not
playing by the same rules here and i i
feel like the images coming out of those
events the met gala the emmy awards
they're getting pretty stark i mean it
you have to bend yourself into some
pretty big pretzels to make
yourself as the elite
wealthy millionaire class into somehow
being oppressed i mean they're trying
very hard and i will say it was it i did
have to watch you know i'm i'm not
michael knowles so my paycheck still
requires me you're specifically on the
entertainment fee that's true
but um
so it was a little less political except
for the images that came out of it were
just
i mean you can't get more marie
antoinette than seeing all the help in
the background masked while the rich and
fabulous megan i've got to stop you
there i've got to stop you there that is
deeply unfair to marie antoinette okay
marie antoinette compare you're going to
compare them to to these degenerates in
hollywood oh my god there's no
comparison to be had they're so they're
so much worse and and uh the the
difference you know even between the
french monarchy and the sort of peasants
in the 19th century it would seem that
the asymmetries of power are even
starker perhaps here today at least when
you're talking about the cultural front
well i mean then you think about this
that you go who had to cover their faces
there
everyone had to be vaccinated and so it
wasn't just that they had to mask it's
that they had to go through all the same
hoops and it was purely performative so
it was almost a sign of submission
because everyone who attended that event
had to take a negative covid test they
had to be vaccinated so they had already
jumped through all those hoops and yet
for the imagery they still had to cover
their faces i mean there's something
very
almost sinister about that right and and
you you can't by the way what they like
to do is say the reason that we still
have these coveted measures is because
of all the conservative white men and
white women karen and there but actually
that's not that's not what's playing out
you this is slightly unrelated and we we
do have to pause it but
you know you have black basketball
players just just a couple days ago
saying no we don't want to take the
vaccine you you you have people showing
up to their school boards who are not
just white men and white women you know
showing up and saying we want this filth
out of our schools the gender ideology
this racism called anti-racism
i think it's cracking that narrative in
a way that's going to be really hard for
them to support we've got to leave it
there megan basham people need to follow
you at the daily wire they need to
follow you everywhere else where can
they find you on social media
i'm on twitter mostly at meg basham so i
hang around in that cesspool come follow
me go follow do not let the fact that
that megan is a
white
woman
stop you from following her she's one of
the good ones i actually don't think
they're that bad in general megan thank
you for being